goated Riz buson s and more added to the
Webster dictionary finally dude Riz just
came out how did they buson been around
s been around goated been around Riz I
feel like is like I just heard it they
really worked Riz was the one where they
were like okay I guess we got to update
it there's too
many Riz came one more and we updated
and it's Riz Miriam Webster really got
the corner market on that [__]
dictionary huh you can get a different
one but I mean it's just the same word
so I guess it doesn't matter 690 new
words have been added to the wh wow dude
RZ goated buson simp let's see what else
a lot of them are digital words because
obviously that is growing oh wow they
they
added Nerf cutscene rage
quit and thirst trap grammable ew an
edge Lord
what is Edge Lord let me look it up a
person who affects a provocative or
extreme Persona especially online
typically used of a man Edge Lords act
like contrarians in the hope that
everyone will admire them as Rebels oh
like a lord of the edge I thought it was
like when somebody's like trying to like
wait make you come after like hours and
hours just teasing you I'm the edge Lord
I'll make you want to come for over 6
hours I'm the edge
Lord where is thou fulum
gland where is thou where is thou
frenulum gland let's see it Belly Up hey
Edge Lorden what are you doing Edge
Lorden oh my Edge Lord
[Laughter]
dude uh signs of a healthy language
include words being created words being
borrowed from other languages and new
meanings being given to the existing
words that's what somebody said here in
a quote on hype Beast
um yeah well I guess they're going to
have to go into a does anyone have a
dictionary or do they just look it up I
I never used a dictionary in my life
remember when [__] your mom would be
like if you don't know how to spell it
look it up in the dictionary and it's
like I I don't know how to [__] spell
it how do I look it up I need to know
how to spell it to [__] look it up
but you know the first letter and then
you go to the second letter and it's
it's it's quite annoying though CU they
got you